Vi trodde ju att det skulle vara helt omöjligt att starta en bank eller bankliknande tjänst.
Är det inte halvst omöjligt?
Absolut att det var svårare sedan, så det gick ju vågen här.
Vi trodde det var omöjligt, sen trodde vi att det var lätt och sen visade vi sig att det var våt.
Det var en naiv eftermiddag där när ni trodde att det var lätt.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 minuter.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Samir Elsa Binni till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Hej tack, jättekul att vara med.
Och vi ska säga att du representerar Juni som ju är, ja det får vi komma till vad det är för någonting, men det är ett hype att bolag som har, finns det någon e-handlare som lyssnar på detta och inte vet vad det är, så har ju de inte lyssnat på någon podd de senaste fyra åren.
Tack, det uppskattar jag.
Vi försöker ju få av en stark position, både för företag generellt men framförallt för e-handlare runtom i Sverige och Europa.
Jag tänker att, innan vi...
Detta är ju inte framgångspodden liksom.
Vi kommer inte sitta och prata om dig som person och alla beslut du har tagit i livet.
Utan vi kommer liksom fokusera på ditt bolag.
Men kan vi inte få en liten liten liten kort intro till dig som person?
Om du gjorde en kontaktannons för, du vet, kanske inte Tinder men liksom Dagens Industri.
Ja, gör man en kontaktannons är det Dagens Industri tänkte jag säga.
Men kort bakgrund av mig, jag är ju göteborgare.
Stolt göteborgare.
Absolut stolt göteborgare, trivs väldigt bra i Göteborg.
Jurist i grunden, jobbat lite med M&A och bolagsrätt.
Sen har jag gjort ganska mycket olika saker.
Jag är ganska bra på att säga nej.
Jag vet inte om man tar med dig en kontaktannons men är väldigt bra på att...
Tror inte det är så jävla vanligt i livet.
Men jag tror att jag har bytt mycket i mitt liv, både arbetsmässigt men också livstidsmässigt.
Jag har jobbat både på Arla med jordbruk, även om jag var inom corporate finance då, men även i egna bolag som jag kanske framför allt har gjort, men även på en amerikansk VC och i ett fintechbolag i Stockholm för Findity.
Och även en kort period på SUP46 som är en inkubator slash co-working för startups.
Det är jättespännande alla de här företagen, men man kan inte utveckla vad du menar med nej.
Det är typ det som sticker ut.
Jag tror att om man tar tillbaks då, nu hoppade jag över den delen, men när jag var ung, så delvis så tror jag att jag var väldigt intresserad av att bygga egna saker tidigt.
Så jag hade ett frukostbolag där jag serverade frukost på ett hotell här i Göteborg i två år.
Och senare var jag också involverad i Sveriges elevkårer, där jag var aktiv i ungefär tio år.
Och de sista åren som ordförande och innan dess som viceordförande.
Och båda de erfarenheterna formade mig väldigt mycket.
För att frukostbolaget, då serverade vi frukost under egentligen tre somrar.
Det var jag och sedan tre stycken deltidsanställda kan vi kalla det.
Och jag älskade verkligen att driva det bolaget och känna att vi kunde göra produkten bättre i det här formet.
Frukostserveringen och vi var ett team och vi sålde mer.
Och i Sveriges elevkårer, i och med att det var under tio år, så fick jag erfarenhet och kanske smak för det här att bygga någonting mer långsiktigt.
Och vi gick från att vara en organisation med kanske 2000 aktiva medlemmar till 120 000 och Sveriges största ungdomsorganisation.
Och båda de erfarenheterna gav mig en ribba för det här är vad arbete och livet kan innebära när man är med duktiga människor, när man har ett gemensamt purpose.
Så att efter det så har jag nog varit väldigt stark på att identifiera och nå det här upp till den känslan.
Är det här vad livet ska ge?
Både personligt men framförallt arbetsmässigt.
Och säga nej då om jag inte tror att det här kommer att utvecklas och blir bättre än de två första erfarenheterna.
Då har jag varit väldigt duktig tror jag på att säga okej men då har jag hittat något nytt.
Så jag bytte från att vara jurist till att driva egna bolag inom framförallt e-handel och performance marketing.
Det var ju ett väldigt stort steg utan väldigt många fördelar av att vara jurist innan så att säga.
Och samma sak sen därefter när jag gick in i Arla.
Så var ju det egentligen, jag ska inte säga helt random, men det var ett beslut som kom från att det lät som en rolig utmaning med roliga människor, var storbolag, något som jag aldrig varit med om.
Jag tänkte säga att utifrån låter ju ganska random.
Ja, men det var väldigt intressant.
Sen visade ju sig också, vilket jag tror är ganska naturligt, att jag inte hade kanske den bästa fitten att vara på ett storbolag i Danmark, jobba inom en corporate finance M&A avdelning.
För så lång tid.
Då slutade jag egentligen utan att ha något annat som jag visste framför mig.
Och egentligen tog jag ett till steg och gick in i SUP46.
Men det är väl det jag menar med bra på att säga nej, att man måste göra det som är rätt mot sig själv.
Våga säga nej utan att kanske ha en full plan framför sig.
Och sen var all in i att hitta nästa steg i livet.
Jag älskar det här att väldigt många entreprenörer har någon sorts udda start.
Man har drivit något skumt bolag för 20 år sedan.
Och så på något sätt ser man det som sin formande punkt som gjorde att man sedan gick vidare och startade i det här fallet en neobank.
Det kallas men liksom de hör inte ihop frukostföretaget på det lokala hotellet i Göteborg.
Men på något sätt blev det ju grunden till det och det är inte det man hade skrivit, om jag skrev en bok om hur man ska starta ett sånt här företag så hade inte jag skrivit, börja med ett frukostföretag när du är 17.
Det är inte så det ser ut.
Men samtidigt är det på något sätt det som formar starten.
Och jag tror det som är intressant är att, även fast det låter väldigt olika, så är det samma ändå utgångspunkt i drivet och att göra saker och ting.
Mycket i livet handlar om att bara göra saker och ting.
Jag älskar att man säljer in det så.
Om någon kom till dig idag och sa, jag skulle vilja bli CFO här på ditt företag.
Jag har ju gjort mycket mackor i mina dagar.
Sen försöker jag sälja in det så och något liknande.
Frukost handlar jag om.
I och för att jag lärde mig frukosten.
Det kommer inte att handla i den.
Nej, jag får säga det.
Frukost handlar jag om service väldigt högre.
Det vi lärde oss, det jag lärde mig då var att vi skapar en bra kundupplevelse, samtidigt som det måste finnas en ekonomi i det här.
Ett exempel så insåg jag ganska snabbt att du köper kanske de billigaste juiceorterna från en grössist, men du häller upp dem i glasflaskor så känns det mycket lyxigare.
Den formen av paketering finns ju med i hela livet oavsett vilken form av business du driver.
Men absolut, det är ett visst ägge.
Jag tror du säger något till dem om...
Jag kommer få så mycket skit av folk nu för att jag avryter hela tiden.
Men jag tänker bara på de här LinkedIn-posterna som är såhär ja, det här lärde jag mig av min praktik under det här året.
Och så är det bara såhär, ordbajser i tre meningar om.
Ja, jag lärde mig att kärlek för människor riktigt.
Absolut, det vet jag som jag lärde.
Men jag tror ändå att såhär, och sen är det såklart såhär, jag tror man ska också vara väldigt krasst med två saker.
Ett är ju att jag hade inte startat ett frukostbolag om jag inte ville tjäna pengar.
Så det fanns ju driv också att tjäna pengar och att förändra sin egen framtid.
Och sen två, jag tror att jag är ganska dålig anställd, alltså det märkte jag när jag var på en advokatbörå, att jag har ju svårt att lämna mig i en herarki och acceptera aktöritet och då har man ju inte så mycket andra val än att försöka starta saker och ting på olika sätt.
Upplever du att du är rebellisk eller upplever du att du bara äger världen?
Alltså typ, är världen din verklighet och du styr vad som ska hända eller är det snarare så att du gör en rebellion mot världen?
Ja, alltså det är en bra fråga.
Jag tror faktiskt att jag, det här låter ju kanske väldigt arrogant men jag hoppas och tror att jag bara har höga standarder och jag vill ojärna sänka dem och det är oftast väldigt svårt att finna en plats med rätt standarder som man inte varit med och skapat själv.
Med det sagt så har jag över tid byggt en väldigt stor acceptans för att mina standarder behöver inte vara bättre än någon annan utan det är olika sätt att utföra sakning på.
Och det är oftast ett av de råden jag ger till unga människor som jag pratar med att det är väldigt viktigt att förstå vem sammanhang man är.
Om du börjar jobba för ett annat bolag så kan du ju lära dig väldigt väldigt mycket.
Men du måste också förstå att det här är inte ditt bolag och du måste ha en acceptans och kompromissar kring det.
Jag tror om jag hade förstått det tidigare så tror jag att jag hade kunnat vara lugnare i skälen och samtidigt lära mig mer på vissa de platser där jag kanske var tyvärr då mer fokuserad på hur jag hade velat ha det än att förstå varför det var på ett visst sätt.
Det låter väldigt rimligt.
Jag märker att det kommer bli svårt att hålla det här avsnittet såpass kort som jag ändå vill göra.
Du pratar ju på det här sättet som gärna är inbjudet till lite frågor men jag ska försöka hålla det fokuserat här.
Så vi släpper dig som privasperson.
Nu får folk gå och googla dig eller någonting.
Nu vill jag fokusera på Juni som ju är det bolaget som du har byggt upp här det senaste.
Och jag använder ändå tjänsten men jag upplever det som någon sorts neobank, kreditgivare, back-end-system och allmän layout som ska göra bokföring lättare eller något sånt.
Vad är det egentligen?
Vad är tjänsten?
Det är en bra fråga.
Jag tror att man ska separera vad som det är idag och vart vi vill vara.
Så kortfattat så är vi ju en neobank för små till mellanstora bolag.
Vad betyder neobank?
Och neobank är ju ett intressant uttryck.
Det här är ju något som finansreprisionen kallar oss för att vi inte har en full banklicens men vi erbjuder banktjänster.
Ja, det låter som en statligt ja.
Och det kom ju också från att EU införde något som heter IMI, Electric Money Institute, som är alltså en licens för någon som får utvärda digitala pengar, men inte fysiska.
Och den stora skillnaden mot en full banklicens är ju egentligen att vi inte får ta dina pengar, som du har hos oss, och låna ut dem till en annan.
Okej, ni kan inte spela ränta på räntaspelet.
Och därför måste vi tänka väldigt annorlunda kring hur vi tjänar pengar på insats av medel.
Vårt mål är ju att få en full banklicens, och det är ju något som vi aktivt undersöker och förbereder oss för.
Men om man talar kort om juni, så började ju vi som en kortprodukt, och har sakta men säkert lagt till fler tjänster för att kunna bli en full bank.
Idag så erbjuder vi egentligen fyra delar.
Så dels talar vi om företagsbanken eller business banking.
Det handlar ju om kontonkort, att kunna skicka pengar till andra länder, att kunna få cashback, att kunna ha konton och olika valutor.
Det var ett av de stora problemen när vi startade.
Det var att väldigt många inte hade USD-kort.
Så de var tvungna att betala med SEC-kort när de skulle betala amerikanska tjänster, typ MailChimp.
Då tyckte man att man inte kan få ett enkelt USD-kort.
Det andra problemet var att när man använde ett kort mycket så fick man inga rewards för det.
Många av våra kunder initialt, de hade stora supplier, alltså leverantörsfakturum fast på kort, de hade också stora utgifter på annonsering och de kanske spenderade flera miljoner men det gav inte dem någon form av värdeutväxling.
Då lanserade vi att vi gav 1% cashback på debitspänn.
Så det var ganska mycket enkla, positiva funktioner på företagsbanken.
Absolut, det var en väldigt stor del av början.
Då kan man också säga att vi lanserade först i England och vi kan komma tillbaka till varför vi gjorde det, men där var ju vår start.
Det är ett sammans med korthantering egentligen, så om du har 20, 30, 40 digitala kort, hur hanterar du dem på bästa sätt både när det gäller bokföringar, men också när det gäller internt för kontroll och för att få förståelse för både din cash position, så är det likt vitet, men också för att kunna sätta gränser för anställda eller olika departement.
Så det är det första delen.
Den andra delen är det vi kallar för utgiftshantering.
Det har vi ju precis lanserat nu, Apple Pay och Google Pay, men det handlar ju i grund och botten om två saker.
Om att kunden ska kunna använda Uni för att stödja sina anställdas utlägg, både fysiskt och virtuellt.
På det så ligger ju också en fakturhantering.
Så att vi har ju sett ganska många kunder som har stora problem med att hämta fakturor och betala dem på bästa möjliga sätt.
Och göra det på ett sådant effektivt sätt.
För att det tar väldigt mycket finansiell administration.
Tredje delen är det vi kallar för treasury.
I grund och botten handlar det om att du ska kunna få översikt över alla dina kontor.
Vi pratade om både den olika banker men också Paypal, Stripe, Klanet etc.
Och kunna flytta pengar mellan beroende på vad du behöver några pengar.
Och även kunna göra betalningar från en plats till olika, eller på olika banker.
Så om du till exempel har en svensk bank, oss, en fast vi har en Neobank.
Om du har sedan en Engels bank och sedan har du en amerikansk.
Så är vår målsättning att du ska kunna från juni utföra betalningar på alla tre.
Sista delen är ju krediten då.
Det vi kallar för finansiering.
Där har vi ett antal olika kreditsprodukter.
Vissa som är väldigt fokuserade just på e-handel.
Till exempel när vi gör olika form av faktura finansiering på leverantörsfakturor.
Så vi egentligen ger kredit för att du ska kunna köpa in dina varor och sedan har du då mellan 30-120 dagar oftast, ibland längre, för att betala tillbaksigt till oss.
Vi har också någonting som vi var först med i annonseringsfinansiering eller media buying financing.
Där vi egentligen tar säkerhet i dina Google-fakturor eller dina Metafakturor och gör att du istället för att betala dem direkt kan förlänga dem, vi säger 90 dagar.
Fördelen med det är att då hinner du få in mer värde från din annonseringskampanj, vilket gör att du då kan återinvestera snabbare.
Sedan har vi kreditkorten och vi har också det som kallas för customized finansiering.
Vilket i grund och botten är egentligen den finansiering du behöver.
Det kan vara för att starta en butik, det kan vara för ett långsiktigt projekt, det kan vara för att köpa ett annat bolag.
Jag bara tänker, det är ju en, skäck det uttrycket, men en fuckload med tjänster.
Och jag menar det på ett snedde, ni är ju fortfarande ett litet bolag och varje sådana här tjänster skulle kunna bli ett väldigt stort bolag.
Alltså, bara att köpa media buyers, måste ju kunna omsätta x antal multimiljarder bara på en europeisk marknad.
Och ni ska väl globalt gissa, ja men, är det inte ganska antingen riskabelt eller att man delar fokus att göra så många olika tjänster direkt?
Absolut, nej men jag tror att det är väldigt riskabelt.
Och då har vi inte ens kommit in på alla de automationer som vi jobbar med.
Men vi har ju ett väldigt stort fokus också på att verkligen ta det hela kundresan.
Alltså från att du gör en betalning till att du har det här bokfört.
Det ska ju gå så snabbt som möjligt.
Och förhoppningsvis med så lite manuella input som möjligt.
Och det är en enorm utmaning och en väldigt stor vision.
Och det är något vi har pratat om från början.
Jag tror att det finns två väldigt viktiga faktorer här.
En är att om du säger om bank så gör de väldigt mycket.
Och om du ska konkurrera med banker då behöver du också göra väldigt mycket.
För att en kund förväntar sig att visa att de kan göra samma som deras bank som de byter ifrån.
Det är det ena.
Men förväntar de sig inte det för att ni har sålt in det på det sättet?
Alltså, någonstans har ni tagit det.
Ni kunde ju ha börjat med två tjänster.
Och bara, varför valde ni att gå vidare och bara utveckla fler tjänster och göra det större och större?
Är det för att ni inte kunde låta bli eller varför att ni såg vinnning där?
Jag tror att det är väl en blandning, men det kommer till den andra punkten, vilket är, jag och vi skulle jag säga som bolag, är övertygade om att kunderna vill användas så få finansiella verktyg som möjligt.
Det fanns under 2018 till 2021 en väldigt stark idé i startupvärlden om att finans kommer de-couple och det kommer bli mer fragmenterat, du kommer använda en leverantör för det här, en för det här, en för det här.
Vi tror inte på det, utan vi tror att det är väldigt få som vill använda tolv olika verktyg för tolv olika tjänster.
Därför är vår vision och idé att samla allting och vara en lösning som absolut inte täcker möjligtvis allt, men majoriteten av behoven hos antingen ett finansteam eller en grundare i ett bolag som vill vara effektivt och digitalt.
Ni är kontrollpanelen för det finansiella i bolaget.
Förhoppningsvis blir vi mer än så med målsättningen att vi ska vara både kontrollpanelen och vi ska vara rösten som hjälper dig och vi ska vara den som utför mycket av de sakerna som du sen bestämmer dig för att göra.
Det är också rent ekonomiskt så finns det stora fördelar.
Man ska inte underskatta att inom det vi kan kalla för banking så väldigt mycket handlar om att maximera LTV, alltså värdet per kund.
Varför?
Jo för att det kostar så mycket att ha en kund.
Med alla kontroller som innebär att ha en kund i en reglerad marknad så måste man ha en ganska stort värde för att nyttan av kunden för båda parter ska bli bra och att man ska kunna ta den här risken.
Hur mer omsättning vi får från dig, hur mer risk kan vi ta på dig?
Och det ser man ganska tydligt även i manens vanlegliga liv med banker, att om man går till Nordea och vill ta ett bolån, då kommer de vilja att du har dina lön hos dem.
De vill att du ska ha din fondaffär hos dem, då får du mer rabatt.
Ibland säljer de in försäkringar.
Allt det hänger samman med den här enkla kalkylen av att okej, det kostar att ta risk, det kostar att on-boarda en kund.
Okej, hur kan vi göra den här affären värd för båda parterna?
Och hur kan vi göra så att vi tjänar då tillräckligt mycket för att också våra aktieägare ska bli nöjda?
Men du har helt rätt att det är ett enormt åtagande.
Det är en stor vision.
Många gånger kan man fastna halvvägs och känna att vi har 20 olika saker men helheten, den har brister.
Jag försöker vara så långsiktig som möjligt.
Och som vi pratar internt i, vi bygger de här byggstenarna.
Och även om alla byggstenar idag inte är perfekta, så når vi ändå platsen där folk kommer att kunna se att det här är ett hus, det är något som faktiskt man gärna tillsammans ger synergier.
Och det finns några synergier.
Om vi gör din PNL automatiskt, via att vi integrerar med alla dina olika payment gateways, din ERP, och vi kan skapa det instantly, då kan vi använda samma PNL till att ge dig instant underwriting, alltså att vi kan utvärdera om ditt bolag kan ta med lån.
Okej, om vi vet hur dina kontostrukturer ser ut, om vi vet vad dina invojset framåt, inte bara att vi kan automatisera att du betalar dina fakturor, vi kan också på ett helt annat sätt ge dig en bild av okej det här är så din likviditet kommer att förändras, här ser vi möjlighet för dig att spara, etc.
Så det finns stora synergier men vägen dit är ju kossa.
Det är inte lätt att starta en bankutmanare, det skulle jag inte hävda.
Jag bara tänker att det finns ju en risk att man bygger iväg sig och gör mängder av saker som kanske inte används eller som kanske krånglar till det.
Hur ser er redan feedback loop ut mot kunder för att se att ni hamnar rätt liksom?
Vi pratar med kunder varje dag.
Har ni kritiska kunder?
Ja absolut, vi har massa kunder som ger feedback.
Idag läste jag två feedback från två nya kunder som hade massa idéer, tankar och absolut kritisk feedback kring olika funktioner.
Och jag tror att en av både målsättningarna och värdena internt är ju att ta det på allvar.
Jag är ju väldigt fokuserad på att vi får aldrig någonsin hamna i en situation där vi bara lättvindigt säger att de tycker så men så tycker inte alla.
Utan vi måste förstå var det kommer ifrån.
Det är mycket svårare i generellt sätt att förstå problem och kundupplevelse än vad man kanske vill.
Jag säger alltid till våra nya anställda att min bedömning är att det tar nio månader för en ny anställd åt oss att verkligen förstå vad gör ett finansteam, hur jobbar man, varför skiljer det sig åt hur man tänker kring bokföring, hur kommer det sig att vissa personer är så inställda på att agera på ett visst sätt, enfatt vi tycker att det är ett annat ju bättre, vad är det för värde någon får ut av det, varför kostar det så mycket mentalt att byta arbetssätt etc.
Med det sagt så måste man ju bygga för framtiden, så ibland är det ju så att någon kommer med feedback, men man måste också våga ta ett beslut om att okej, den feedbacken är inte prioriterad eller relevant just nu, men vi får mycket feedback.
Ja, du har ett hårt spamfilter.
Ja, jag är lite fascinerad av den här resan som ni har gjort, för att nu vet jag inte exakt tiden här eller timelineen, men på ganska få år så har ni ju, dels har ni vuxit extremt snabbt i värdering och ni har tagit in med Svenska motmet oerhört mycket pengar på kort tid.
Och jag undrar lite hur man fungerar i hjärnan under den tiden.
Under de två åren när det verkligen liksom tog fart, skulle du säga att du bytte personlighetsdrag då?
Gick du längs gatan lite kaxigare, började du bete i annorlunda, kände du pressen på ett annat sätt, blev det helt plötsligt inte din vision?
Alltså jag bara funderar på hur hjärnan hanterar den situationen.
Den är inte så vanlig liksom.
Jag tror, jag hoppas ju ändå, nu kanske det är bättre tid att fråga andra om vad jag har ändrat personligen.
Vi klipper in tre ansnäddas.
Vi gjorde ju mycket misstag, det ska man ju ändå säga.
När vi tog in väldigt mycket pengar under de åren, vi tog in pengar egentligen från 2020 till juni 2022, då var ju då vi tog in alla varor under.
Jag har räknat på att ni tog in ungefär en och en halv miljard plus en miljard i lånefinansiering.
Ja men det kan nog stämma, jag tror det är lite mer till och med, men det kan nog stämma.
Det beror ju på dollarkurs.
Jag tror generellt sett att jag kände nog väldigt mycket tacksamhet, det förändrade ju mitt liv också oerhört mycket hela den resan.
Men sen så inser man ju nu i efterhand att det kanske inte var så normalt som man trodde då.
Det är det framför allt.
Tror du verkligen att det var normalt då?
Jo men jag tror att det ändå var, men när man är i det så blir man ju också, jämförelsen blir ju med väldigt många andra, blir ju inte med de som inte gör det, utan jämförelsen blir ju med de som gör det.
Så när vi pratade internt så jämförde vi oss med amerikanska motsvarigheter och då kändes det ju väldigt normalt för de gjorde ju det.
Men det som händer tror jag är att man klart, på ett sätt så gör man ju misstag som man kanske inte trodde man skulle göra.
Jag tror definitivt att vi har spenderat för mycket pengar på olika saker.
Jag tror definitivt att vi anställde för många på kort tid.
Vi anställde fel personer.
Många gånger så byggde vi fel saker.
Vi blev alldeles för kortsiktiga.
Och det som händer som jag tror många entreprenörer underskattar är att kravbilden ökar enormt.
Jag tror inte att det nödvändigtvis fick mig att må dåligt eller att känna mig stressad, men det är de facto så att om någon ger dig en och en halv miljard då kommer de att förvänta sig väldigt mycket av dig.
Och inte bara av dig utan av hela bolaget såklart.
Och det hände ju och det gick väldigt snabbt för oss att gå från att vi satt fem stycken på kaféer och tänkte att det här var en lifestyle business men att vi skulle kunna bygga det här var 20 personer till att det fanns en förväntan på att vi om det skulle bli 500 personer finnas i hela världen och vi skulle varenda månad växa med 50 procent.
Sen blev det ju väldigt naturligt för oss att många av de här förväntningarna och kanske även våra misstag kunde rättas till med tanke på att marknaden förändrades så drastiskt, speciellt i den tech-världen.
Men det har absolut varit en väldigt speciell resa.
Jag har väldigt svårt att förminna mig hur saksingen var innan juni.
Är det som innan efter barn?
Ja, på många sätt.
Man vet att det fanns, men man kan inte riktigt minnas hur man kunde ha trött innan.
Hur mycket frihet hade man egentligen?
Jag tror absolut att det finns en koppling till det.
Och även just att det blir väldigt naturligt.
För mig, den kravbilden vi har idag, det känns som vi alltid haft den, en fast jag vet om att så inte i fallet.
Så det är definitivt förändrats.
Generellt, men jag ska ändå säga att jag känner, och jag tror att en av anledningarna att vi lyckades ta in de här pengarna, förutom våra resultat och det teamet vi har byggt upp som har varit helt fantastiskt, är just det faktum att jag tror att vi har varit väldigt ödmjuka, och inte nödvändigtvis, även fast det kanske verkar så externt, har känt oss så hypade.
Jag tror också det, jag hör det samma med att vi sitter i Göteborg, och är ganska lugna individer.
Det är inte, jag tror att det här var ett annat som var i London.
Ja, och jag kan väl också säga det att ni, ni kan ju framstå som ganska lugna individer, men ni är ju också extremt säljfokuserade.
Det är ju inte så att, jag tror inte att jag har haft en enda dialog med någon hos er som inte har försökt sälja in en tjänst, eller se till att jag säger, nu mötte jag ju upp Ruben som är erans CFO, tror jag, härute i lobbyn och han bjöd på en kopp kaffe och det tog ju 22 sekunder innan han snackade om olika kreditkort och olika, och jag är som sagt redan kund men han var ju sån där, ja du vet att du kan flytta över detta, du skulle kunna göra såhär.
Och inte på ett, utan bara för att han liksom inte kan låta bli är min känsla.
Ja, jag blir jättestolt här.
Det är ju så.
När jag har snackat med dig så har det också varit såhär, ja men jag bor i Göteborg, chalalala.
Du förresten har du funderat på att ha en sån här, jag bara upplever att ni inte kan låta bli.
Nej men vi älskar det vi gör och sen är det ju så att i en startup så måste man ju vidare och det menar jag både rent produktmässigt men framför allt kommersiellt.
Om vi stannar nu så dö vi ju.
Det tror jag har blivit ändå DNA, och jag tror att alla hos oss känner det.
Alla kan också hjälpa till.
Alla kan i varenda samtal utanför att vara påträngande men ändå sälja in juni mer.
Hur gör man för att skala upp en vision på det sättet?
För du beskrev det inte som en lifestyle business men att ni ändå kanske tänkte att ni skulle rådda er på ett litet team och sen på ett år eller ett och ett halvt år så insåg ni att shit det här är en helt annan vision vi jobbar med nu.
Hur skalades den visionen?
Tog ni hjälp att skala upp den visionen?
Blev det bara så eller var det investerarna som skalade upp den åter?
Hur skalades visionen?
Jag tror det som hände var att vi var extremt naiva i början.
I början var vi så här vi hade en figma av det som vi tänkte oss vara en neobank med ett antal olika funktioner och det här trodde vi krävde ett års arbete för att bygga och sedan hur mer vi byggde och hur mer den finansiella samarbeten vi hade.
Så insåg vi att det här var ett mycket större projekt.
Och absolut att investerare var en del av det genom att ställa vissa frågor men det blev också en konsekvens av att bara från början haft en produktvision som var en viss storlek.
Den här logiken är ganska intressant för om du har en viss produkt att bygga och du säger att du tror att den kommer att kosta 25 miljoner att bygga.
Och så säger någon, om vi ska vara med och investera 25 miljoner då måste ju utväxlingen, det är den bästa scenarioet, vara kanske en miljard och då får vi en bra multipel.
Och när man då har en miljard som någon form av marknadsstorlek så bör man ju tänka annorlunda kring, vad är det vi ska bygga egentligen, vad får man in kunder och hur mycket människor behövs det.
Och så växlas det hela tiden av förväntan, vad någon ska få tillbaka och sen ens insikt om vad det faktiskt kommer att kräva att nå dit.
Så jag tror att det där var ganska naturligt, men det startade ju med att ha en naiv, väldigt stor vision som vi trodde var mycket mindre.
Kan du känna en rädsla för att det är så mycket pengar i omlopp?
Det är ganska stora summor som spelas.
Tänker du på dem som pengar eller tänker du på dem som pokechips när man spelar?
Jag menar inte att du spelar med pengar, jag menar bara att man ser dem som ett verktyg.
Jag tror att när vi såg de första, eller nu pratar vi om dem i vår sista runda nu när vi tog in över en miljard, så är det en fascinerande summa, det blir väldigt konstigt.
Din mamma eller pappa, de kan ju inte anser att det är rimligt.
Eller mina föräldrar tycker fortfarande att de kan inte förstå att folk köper en skivstång för flera tusen, det är helt korkat.
Har inte folk köpt färdigt skivstång i snart.
Framförallt ens föräldrar är ju så här, nej det kan inte stämma, du måste ha tagit fel på 3-nollet där.
Min mamma är ju kommunist och hon tycker att det här är långt ifrån rimligt, men sen tror jag hon ändå är stolt, hoppas jag.
Men absolut, och det är klart att i min värld så blir det inte mina pengar, utan meningen är att vi ska tjäna med de här pengarna för att bygga ett bolag som är värt mycket mer, och de ska räcka så länge som det krävs för att vi ska kunna göra det.
Jag tror att i vår bransch krävs det ju väldigt mycket pengar av egentligen två starka anledningar.
Ett för att kunna låna ut pengar, och två för att ha förtroende.
Jag menar du vill ju inte vara hos en bank eller neobank som inte har pengar själv.
Så det är en aspekt av det.
Men jag tar det väldigt allvarligt.
Jag menar vi har ju fått ett förtroende och det förtroendet vill vi hantera på bästa sätt.
Med det sagt så är det ju så att många andra entreprenörer som jag möter som kanske känner mer ångest eller negativa känslor, det tror jag bygger på att de inte har en, ibland i alla fall, men man har felinvesterare eller investerare som har inte en ärlig relation med.
Jag är väldigt tydlig med våra investerare att de här pengarna, ni har litar på mig att förvalta på bästa sätt men det är ju ändå en stor sannolikhet att vi inte skulle ha lyckats.
Nu har ju den sannolikheten minskat eller risken har ju minskat över tid och nu är vi ju över den storleken att vi kommer aldrig försvinna.
Men det är ju viktigt att man förstår att det är en risk nånting.
Det är inte en självklar sak att vi skulle nå till de höjderna som de hoppas på.
Och det måste man kunna tala om.
Och de måste kunna ge mig feedback och jag måste göra det jag tror på.
Och sen får vi se vad slutsresultatet är om tio år.
Det jag har sagt till dem är att vi gör ju absolut vårt bästa.
Och i min drömvärld så är juni mitt sista jobb så att säga.
Men det är ju de enda löften jag kan ge.
Utöver det så är det ju både misstag vi kan göra i externa konsekvenser, förändringar, vare sig det på räntemarknaden eller hur det går för företag i Europa och i världen, som spelar väldigt stor roll.
Och det ska man ju ha med sig.
Jag möter ibland entreprenörer som kanske har fått in mycket, mycket mindre pengarna, tio miljoner men tycker att det är jättejobbigt att det kanske inte har blivit som de hade sagt i sitt däck till den här investeraren.
Men en investerare måste vara professionell.
Du kan inte lägga in pengar i företag om du inte förstår att de pengarna med ganska stor risk kan bli noll.
Och jag bara gissar att när hela, vad ska man säga, break it media skriker att alla bolag ska bli lönsamma så det finns liksom ingen chans för ett sånt här bolag att vara helt lönsamt under ganska många år.
För ni måste ju ha en enorm utlåning i takt med att ni växer och även utvecklings...
Alla vill att vi ska kunna vara lönsamma.
Men det finns ingen av våra investerare som vill att vi ska vara lönsamma.
Utan så fort vi är i en position där vi skulle kunna välja att vara lönsamma då är ju utgångspunkten att vi ska resa mer pengar.
För man vill ju alltid investera så man når den största opportunityn på lång sikt.
Och det tror jag ändå är svårt ibland att förstå.
Men så fort vi har Tempel vuxit väldigt mycket då är inte diskussionen okej men nu håller vi nere på investeringar för att vi då ska kunna på sista raden visa.
Utan då är ju utgångsläget okej, hur kan vi med det här som resultat ta så stor marknadsandel som möjligt, gå in i nya marknader etc.
Det blir som en belånad fastighetsaffär, ni ska ha avkastning på kapital, inte resultat på sista.
Ja men det är så startups funkar.
Många startups har enorma värden, nu kanske de kallas scale ups efter en tid, men de kanske har gått förlust i 20 år, men det betyder inte att det är en dålig underliggande affär, utan det du vill se är en equity journey, alltså en resa i ditt värde på kapitalet som är väldigt stark.
I vårt fall har vi som målsättning att vara lönsamma på sista raden i Q1 2026, och vi har runway, alltså pengar att nå dit och förbi, men anledningen till att vi vill vara lönsamma då är för att sätta rätt fokus internt, men också att ha makten i våra egna händer att kunna ta nästa steg, utan att vara i behov av någon annan, vilket jag tycker är viktigt.
Det har ju inte att göra med att jag tror att vi aldrig kommer resa mer pengar, det tror jag definitivt vi kommer att göra.
Jag tänkte säga med risk för att ha en fråga som jag inte kommer att få svar på, det var ganska länge sedan ni tog in kapital i den här världen, kanske det räknas så i alla fall.
Är det för att ni känner att ni ska nå till den här punkten först, eller är det för att marknaden helt enkelt är skit för att ta in pengar?
Jag tror marknaden är skit, men vi har ju inte pratat om att ta in pengar på länge och kommer inte göra det så att jag skall inte utvärdera baserat på egen erfarenhet där.
Vi får ju väldigt mycket kontakter av olika investerare som vill träffa oss.
Jag tror ju definitivt att kraven har ökat markant.
Det beror ju klart på vilken industri.
Om du är inom AI så kanske de har minskat.
Men generellt har de ökat.
Och det är ju någonting som vi försöker att inte tänka på.
För egentligen spelar det väldigt liten roll för oss.
Vi har satt en plan på att använda de här pengarna på bästa möjliga sätt för att nå både lönsamhet men också en viss storlek och en viss produktutbud, egentligen bland annat 2026.
Och det är fullt fokus.
Och sen, klart att om någon kommer med en erbjudande innan tar vi det allvarligt, men det finns egentligen ingen anledning att lägga energi på kapitalresning om du inte behöver det eller har det som en del av någon pågående plan.
Hur är tanken, nu svarar du på den andra men du kanske inte vill svara på denna men du sa att detta skulle, du kunde ändå ha någon sorts förhoppning om att detta var det sista du gjorde.
Ja, det hoppas jag verkligen.
Tänker du att det är någon stor finansiell aktör som ska köpa upp er eller är det att du ska bara sälja av?
Vad tror du att juni kommer uppgå i eller blir det en egen stor?
Jag hoppas ju att vi blir en av de nya, vad kan jag kalla, global utmanarna inom banking.
Om jag får drömma så hade ju jag fortfarande varit vd och...
Men inte jobbat.
Jo, jag hoppas verkligen att jag jobbar.
Inte för mycket kanske, men jag tror ju att om du är vd så måste du jobba en del.
Till och med väldigt mycket ofta.
Men jag hade nog velat att vi om 20-30 år fanns i en stor del av världens största marknader.
Vi var en av fem globala utmanare när det gällde både small-
och mid-market banking.
Och kanske framförallt att vi hade varit en del av att revolutionera vad en bank faktiskt kan erbjuda för tjänster till sina kunder.
Och hur det kan inte bara ge dig finansiell lättnad i form av likvider eller basic tools, men också verkligen kan vara den fundamentet som tar bort den enorma kostnaden väldigt många av våra kunder och företag känner när det gäller just admissivbörda.
Det tror jag är helt avgörande om man ska sänka trösklarna, driva och starta bolag.
Och på det då så hade jag ju önskat, och det jag ser framför oss, att vi hade kunnat ge insikter som var konkreta och som hjälpte kunder att faktiskt driva en bättre affär utan finansiell kunskap kontinuerligt.
Är det stora drömmålet på sikt att ni ska bli ett av de här systemen som man jackar på?
Säg till exempel, vi har tredjepartsvärden, tredjepartslogistik.
Och sen så kopplar man in ett juni och så ser man att det här är lönsamt, det här är inte lönsamt, det här kan vi finansiera, och så låter man det bara rulla automatiskt ihop med någon sorts AI-algoritm som skriver kontexttexter och köper insorg som passar ihop med tredjepart.
Så att enskilda entreprenörer ska kunna sitta hemma och bara mala, är det liksom en vision eller trodde att världen kommer fortsätta vara så här som den är idag?
Nej men jag tror definitivt att det finns en del av vår vision som liknar det.
Jag tror mycket också handlar om att få möjlighet, access till alla de finansiella verktyg som du behöver.
Lite som i början där med USD-kort, men också hur man ska tänka kring likviditet.
Det är väldigt avgörande vilka former av överföringar du gör.
Det är en väldigt stor del.
Det andra är såklart insikterna i realtid, att du ska få rätt insikter och sen rätt möjlighet att agera, exekvera på de insikterna.
Jag tror aldrig att det kommer vara bara en person i många fall, utan det kommer säkert vara en bolag med finansteams.
Men vår förhoppning är ju ändå att vi kommer att vara ett exoskelett i de teamen, där de kommer att kunna göra mycket mer.
Och kanske framför allt fokusera på de viktiga sakerna, istället för den monotoma administrationen, som de onödigt behöver göra dag ut dag in.
Jag ser på många treasuryteam och för den delen grundare, som sitter och loggar in bara för att kolla saldot.
Varför skulle man behöva göra det?
Hur kommer det sig att människor än idag sitter och ska försöka teckna ner Excel, vad man har för incoming, outgoing, på olika konton runtom i världen, varje dag?
Det låter ju som att en dator kan göra det bättre än vad en människa kan göra.
Och ändå sitter alla med Excel.
Och det här är ju duktiga människor.
De här människorna, det är inte så att de kommer att försvinna, de kommer att kunna andra mycket bättre saker.
Samma sak när det gäller regler.
Om du har regler för utgiftshantering, det är klart att du inte ska behöva egentligen ens ha någon form av manuell inverkan förutom att möjligtvis sätta upp de här reglerna.
Det ska styra sig av sig själv.
Om du betalar till en europeisk leverantör och de vill ha euro och du har mer svenska kronor på din konton, varför ska du ens behöva tänka på att föra över till euro, kolla FIS och liknande?
Hur kommer det sig att det inte bara sker på bästa möjliga sätt?
Om du har savings, vad den kan vara.
Kanske framför allt också, varför ska du behöva vänta på långa rapporter för att förstå din likviditet, för att förstå vad din P&L är, är det här bra?
Är det värt som du sa att ge en kredit till det här?
Borde du, när du köper in de här varorna, hur mycket har du tjänat på att ta 90 dagars kredit versus att använda dina egna pengar?
Hur frustrerad är du över att inte alla använder juni?
Jag kan ju känna att du har en viss passion i den här.
Nu ser jag inte alla ditt kroppsbråk, men du kör ju mer italienskt än svenskt, om du förstår vad jag menar.
Nej men jag tycker att det är vårt ansvar.
Vi har inte någon rätt till att få kunder, utan det är vårt ansvar i och med att bygga en väldigt bra kredit.
Ja herregud vad politiskt korrekt svarat.
Men jag förstår vad du menar, ja.
Jag tänker på en annan grej här.
Det är ofta du som är ansiktet utåt för Juni.
Men ni var ett team där i början.
Ja, jag och Anders.
Vad gör Anders och vad är er relation?
Vår relation är väldigt nära.
Anders är vår CTO och min medgrundare.
Han leder ju all engineering och är min närmsta person.
Vi äger ju lika mycket av Juni och är ju jämlika, men har en väldigt tydlig uppdelning internt av att jag är vd och tar operativa beslut när det gäller verksamheten.
Anders leder ju och tar alla beslut när det gäller engineering.
Men när det gäller strategi och liknande så är det vi tillsammans som sätter det.
Ibland träffar man ju människor och vill bara fortsätta ta en till öl, man vill inte sluta prata och lyssna.
Lite som förälskelse med vänner.
En bromance.
Ja exakt och vi träffades och fick verkligen en sådan.
Och det gick ganska snabbt och vi insåg ganska snabbt just att vi hade samma erfarenheter kring e-handel och framförallt.
Hans fru har ju en e-handel, hans fru syster har en e-handel.
Och vi började prata väldigt mycket om den här finansiell administrationen, kostnaden, folk hatar att göra bokföring, folk hatar att skicka in kvitton.
Hur kommer det sig att ingen vet hur de här kampanjerna går, hur mycket pengar man lägger på olika saker, hur kommer det sig att folk betalar på fel sätt, varför använder du den här, löser du inte den här.
Massa sådana här ganska basic frågor.
Men det var ju grogrunden.
Och sen när vi valde att starta i juni så kändes det väldigt naturligt.
Det var väldigt lätt, även fast som jag började med att säga att tror jag att ambitionsnivån var lite mer enkel.
Så kändes det som att vi måste bara göra någonting tillsammans.
Vad var den allra första idén?
Vilket var det allra första problemet ni tänkte att ni skulle ta?
Det första problemet handlade väldigt mycket om lagret mellan bankerna.
Om du har alla dina banker här och du har alla dina company-utgifter så är det egentligen annonsering, suppliers och liknande.
Och vi upplevde att det fanns inget bra mellanlager för att ta bort all administration när det gäller reconciliation, alltså det som är förbokföringen.
Att få hemt in alla underlagen, att få fram alla insights i realtid, lite treasury, saldohantering, allting sånt.
Hur kommer det sig att jag behöver gå in på Paypal för att få Paypal-informationen, jag behöver gå in på Nordea för att få Nordea.
Varför kan jag inte se Nordea och Paypal tillsammans?
Det här var ju ändå ett tag sedan, så nu har det ju hänt lite mer.
Men det var ju grunden så att egentligen en blandning mellan det vi kan kalla för lite open banking, ganska mycket när det gäller bokföring och administration.
Och sen sist men inte minst då att kunna få egentligen bredare insights, typ, okej du borde egentligen betala det här på det här sättet, du borde skicka de här pengarna hit, etc.
Det vi insåg väldigt snabbt var att väldigt många vi pratade med förstod inte riktigt varför man skulle ha ett mellanlager, hur kommer det sig att ni inte bara blir den man använder för att använda de här korten, etc.
Och sen visade det sig också då att det var väldigt mycket svårare att bygga ett mellanlager, för att vad hade de här andra aktörerna för incitament att ge oss rätt data, ge oss rätt tillgång till att ta actions.
Det var en amerikan som i början vi pratade med som har en PE firma i New York, Daniel, väldigt galen gubbe, han skrev såhär med caps lock typ, ett mail till oss, eller skickat ut en survey, vad är dina problem, vad tycker du är dina e-handlare som du äger helt eller delvis, har för stora finansiella utmaningar, har du berätt på administrationen, och sen hade han skrivit några svar och så hade jag följt upp, och så svarade han, troligtvis var han full tror jag, skrev han såhär, I don't want another app, I want a better bank.
Sen två uttrycksecken.
Och vi var ganska mycket emot det initialt för att vi trodde att det skulle vara helt omöjligt att starta en bank eller bankliknande tjänst.
Är det inte halvt omöjligt?
Absolut att det var svårare sen, så det gick ju vågen här, vi trodde det var omöjligt, sen trodde vi att det var lätt, och sen visade vi sig att det var väldigt svårt.
Det var en naiv eftermiddag där när ni trodde att det var lätt.
Framförallt trodde vi att det var lätt att göra det i England, för det som hände var att vi gjorde massa research, hur startar man en ny bankutmanare?
Då visade vi sig att det fanns väldigt många fler leverantörer i UK, framförallt för att London är ett större fintechcentrum, men också för att Pund är en större valuta.
Så då kontaktade vi massa av de här leverantörerna.
Du kan tänka dig att det som kallas för banking är service, olika former av kortprovider.
Det finns någon som heter Binnsponsor, alltså någon som sponsrar dig att bli medlem med en mastercard, eller de är medlemmar, så du blir medlem vid de.
När man pratar med deras säljare så låter allting väldigt enkelt.
Så vi var ju verkligen ett sånt naivt lyckorus av att det här låter hur bra som helst.
Men det var ju fortfarande dyrt, så när vi reste vår sidrunda så var vi ju måste ha in två miljoner euro för att det här ska gå.
Annars kommer, om vi tar mindre än 23 miljoner kanske i den växtkursen då, då kommer det aldrig bli av.
Det visar sig att det kostade ganska mycket mer än 23 miljoner att komma till den nivå vi trodde vi skulle komma med 23 miljoner.
När vi lanserade i juni, det här är alltså sista februari 2021, lanserade, vi hade en ganska lång waiting list, men det var väldigt få som ville ha den formen av alfa.
Så vi hade första månaden 24 aktiva bolag, och du vet det här var den sämsta produkten någonsin.
Du kunde inte se dina transaktioner, men du kan tänka dig att du gör en transaktion, du kunde inte se vad de transaktionerna var.
Du kunde inte egentligen sätta några spärrar, eller du vet det här, det fanns ingenting.
Vad kunde man göra?
Bra fråga.
Man kunde sätta upp de rituella kort, man kunde sätta kategorier, du kunde ha väldigt hög spännlimit, det var ett av de problemen som indikerades först.
Många av de som spenderade på Meta, de hade problem med att de fick block, att korten slutade funka, inte för att de inte hade pengar, utan för att de hade typ 200 000 i limit, inte via de själva utan via banken.
Då pratade vi med Visa, och Visa sa att om ni ger oss den här informationen per kund, då kan vi höja limiten till 10 miljoner.
Då plötsligt finns det massor av kunder därute som kanske spenderar 4 miljoner på Meta, som känner att det är jätteskönt att de vill ta dem till 10 miljoner.
Det låter jättenkelt och då kan man fråga sig varför gör inte andra banker det?
Gissningsvis för att det är jättejobbigt administrativt för dem att lägga upp det på det sättet.
Och det är deras tech hårdkordat.
Om du ringer SEB idag och frågar om du kan få 10 miljoner i spendimet på debittkort, då kommer de nog bara säga att det är omöjligt att göra så här.
Utan att säga för mycket.
Så det var en av de sakerna.
En annan sak var ju att vi hade cashback och vi hade ett sätt att sätta kort per användare så att du kunde sätta det också för här är annonseringskortet, det här är meta-kort.
Fick vi en fråga, tror jag vecka två, och bara men okej nu har jag fört över 100 000 euro till mitt Unicom.
Som man gör.
Ja men då fanns det ju någon sån där.
De var älskade och de var ju också människor som jag har väldigt stor respekt och kärlek för för att en av dem är fortfarande vår tredje största kund.
Och hans bolag då, han hatade ju sina engelska bankar, han hatade dem.
Men det var inte ens han faktiskt, det var hans CFO som skrev till oss och var såhär, men hur tar jag ut pengar?
Vi bara va?
Och vi hade inget sätt att kunna withdraw, alltså du kunde ju skicka in pengar till oss och du kunde spändera dem men att skicka tillbaks dem om du behövde pengar annars stanns, det hade vi inte ens med.
Så då satt ju några av våra fantastiska utvecklare mitt i natten och la till den här funktionen då att du kunde skicka pengar tillbaks till där de hade kommit ifrån.
Var det egentligen ni då som bara skickade över pengar och sen löste allt det i bakgrund?
Nej men det gjorde vi också men vi insåg att den här frågan skulle komma upp så då var vi ju tvungna att lösa den här så svårt som möjligt.
Nej men det gjorde vi i back end till just den kunden.
Jag älskar det, det är skitroligt ju.
Får man fråga hur stor andel av bolaget du äger idag?
Ja men det tror jag, jag vet inte om det är öppet men aktieboken går ju att hämta ut.
Jag äger ju mellan, jag har ju ett antal optioner också, så jag ligger väl mellan 16 och 17 procent, jag och Anders.
Anders har samma.
Var det några fler privatpersoner som var med från start?
Mm, så vi är ju några stycken, de första anställda, hade ju optioner och även aktier.
Vissa av dem gick in med lite pengar också initialt.
Och sen framförallt i vår sidrunda så hade vi ett antal änglar med.
Fem stycken, om jag inte minns mer.
De allra första personerna som gick in, vad var det du letade efter i de personerna?
Det var egentligen teamet, alltså kompetenserna vi behövde.
Och utan dem hade det aldrig gått.
Vi hade aldrig nått ut till kunderna på det sättet som vi gjorde initialt.
Vi växte ju enormt de första sex månaderna.
Men då var det inte samma sån här bromance-grej som i Anders här, utan det handlades snarare om ett skillset som...
Alla dem vi hade med från början, möjligtvis munnat från en, hade vi ändå en relation till.
Och det krävde ju nästan för att man skulle, utan lön, i tolv månader kämpa med någonting som kunde gå lite hur som helst.
Så vi hade absolut en nära relation och av de första fem så är det fyra av några av mina närmsta vänner.
Och den femte hade vi väldigt tur med, en av våra utvecklare som kom in, få tips också från en annan, och har varit en fundamental del i både bygga produkten, designen och kundupplevelsen.
Och alla de fick ju en del av juni initialt, och tror jag är väldigt glad över det.
Jag hoppas att ni har gått uppåt.
Ni har ju, som du säger, du har ju någon sorts 20-30-årig vision här, och du sa ändå att du såg dig själv som vd.
Hur tror du att du kommer behöva förändras för att faktiskt vara vd då?
Vad är det du saknar idag i dina ledaregenskaper?
Hur är du som person idag som inte kommer funka då?
Eller hade du kunnat hoppa in om 20 år och bara rodda det här när det omsätter 500 miljarder och du behöver slåss med de här stora bankerna i USA?
JP Mori, exakt.
Det krävs nog väldigt mycket både kompetensmässigt och erfarenhet mässigt.
Jag har ju aldrig lätt ett bolag med 300 anställda plus.
Så klart att det kommer att krävas en enorm vilja att utvecklas som ledare och lära sig ett annat form av ledarskap.
Är det något du jobbar med?
Jag tror att jag tar ju dagen som det kommer.
Mycket av det handlar ju om att vara förberedd för förändring, öppen för det och ta det på allvar.
För varje steg vi har tagit så har det ju blivit svårare.
Det är verkligheten.
Jag tror också det är en sådan lögn som ibland man tror på att om jag tar in pengar och vi lyckas i första skedet då kommer det bli lättare för mig.
Så är det ju absolut inte.
Kraven ökar ju.
Och då får vi en annan relation med människor.
Men när de första vi, när vi var 15 personer, då var vi ju nära människor som gick ut och tog glatt vin och ja men alla hade på något sätt en relation till varandra som personer.
Idag såklart att om du är 180 personer då kommer du ju ha anställda i andra delar av Sverige som inte har en emotionell relation till dig på något sätt utan du i deras ögon kanske grundare, kanske vd.
Du måste ju tänka på det ledarskapet helt annat sätt.
Du måste bygga mycket mer strukturer.
Mycket av det vi gör idag och som är i grunden till mitt ledarskap är ändå vårt operational framework.
Många gånger försöker jag komma ihåg att det är mycket viktigare hur du strukturerar både människor, incitament, ansvarsområden, uppföljningar, allting när det gäller just grupper än hur du själv agerar i en en-till-en situation.
Och sen är det också det som man måste vänja sig vid, det är att du jobbar med väldigt mycket människor som är extremt mycket bättre än dig.
Så är ju min verklighet, om vi ser på vårt ledarskap, inklusive Anders, Anders är ju inte bara en fantastisk ingenjör, utan också en fantastisk CTO.
Jag är ju nog den i vårt ledarskap som har minst domänkunskap eller kompetens inom ett område.
Och det måste man ju verkligen acceptera, omfamna och förstå sin plats i det.
Ja, jag skrev något inlägg om det för något år sen eller någonting, att nu är jag sämst på bolaget.
Jag är inte bäst på någonting längre.
Ja men det blir ju så.
Men vad skulle du säga är den största skillnaden på dig idag och för fem år sen?
Kan du se att du har förändrats i någonting?
Är det några drag som är annorlunda?
Du får inte säga att du är lugnare nu.
Jag är absolut inte lugnare.
Jag är ganska passionerad med att skapa stress.
Jag har nog många negativa sidor i den meningen.
Jag driver ju hårt på.
Det kräver mycket.
Jag kan klippa in mig att det är rätt tydligt också.
Som sagt, jag var i dialog med er för kanske ett år sedan eller nånting.
Och så ville vi ha en tjänst och så hade jag missuppfattat den tjänsten.
Och så hade du och jag en diskussion.
Det var bara såhär lite random.
Jag tror att ni ringde upp mig klockan 11 på kvällen för att lösa den tjänsten.
Och mitt första svar var liksom, vad fan ringer du nu för?
Det här är en helt oft tid att ringa på.
Det är typ fredag kväll klockan 11.
Det var ganska tydligt att du typ hade sagt, ring upp och lösa detta nu.
Så jag kan bara säga att det märks på andra sidan.
Ja, jag tror att ibland har du fördelar.
Jag hoppas ändå att du har en okej upplevelse.
Ja, jag blir bara nöjd.
Det är kanske inte så vanligt.
Jag tror att jag känner också det.
Jag tror att man rätt den här.
Jag är väldigt action-oriented.
Om något händer så vill jag att det kanske inte löser imorgon, men vi ska påbörja att lösa det.
Jag är definitivt passionerad på både ett bra och ett dåligt sätt.
Det är inte så att jag alltid håller mig lugn.
Jag tror att den största förändringen, om jag ska vara ärlig, är att jag blir mer långsiktig.
Det har varit en jättestor utmaning mentalt.
Att inte bara fokusera på det som är framför den, utan försöka lyfta blicken och tänka, okej, vad är det som är viktigast?
Hur spelar det här ut sig på två, tre år?
Det är väldigt lätt att vara, man fokuserar bara på nästa vecka och de närmaste målen.
Det handlar också såklart om strukturer när man sätter mål, men det handlar också om när man blir större och har mer överlevnadskapacitet, så måste man, om man förändrar sig som ledare och fokuserar på de breda dragen.
En av de anledningarna, inte bara för att du ska få lägga din tid rätt, men också för att du ska respektera dina medarbetare, att det inte är sunt, för de måste lägga mycket fokus på här och nu och närtid, att gå in som ledare och ta det jobbet åt dem, och det sänker viljan att utföra och känslan att vara betrodd och sedd.
Så det är något som jag har jobbat med mycket.
Och den andra delen, jag tror att det är bra, men man blir kallare i viss mån av att jobba med många människor, och såklart också ibland uppleva både med och motgångar, och förstå olika människors incitament.
Du kanske jobbar för oss men har en helt annan idé, men du kanske inte tänker att du ska vara en 30-årig, och då måste man ju, som ledare tror jag, inte bli kall i den meningen att man inte känner, att man älskar att vara i samma team, men man måste också förstå att det här är ett team, och kanske ännu mer så för dig, att jag kanske är, det här är det enda laget för mig, och det finns naturliga skäl för det, och jag äger en stor del av det jag har startat det, men för dig ser du det här som att du kommer att vara med i några år sedan gå vidare, och det tror jag också att man måste respektera.
Så det har absolut varit en förändring också.
Också den personen utnyttjar ju bolaget av ett mål, och då får man ju också utnyttja dem för ett mål.
Alltså jag bara menar att se det på ett schysst sätt mellan två öppen.
Ja och det blir ju förhoppningsvis något som ger båda något väldigt positivt.
Jag blir jätteglad när våra tidiga anställda startar nya bolag, eller är på ännu bättre jobb, men det är ju det som är meningen.
Du blir glad, blir du egentligen?
Ja men jag blir faktiskt väldigt glad.
Vet du vad jag sjuka med det är?
Ibland tänker jag att om vi ändå misslyckas så har vi ändå gett det här.
Ja, nej nej nej.
Nej, nej nej nej.
Om någon snor mina anställda och de växer i helvete vad sur jag hade blivit, jag hade inte kunnat säga vad jag hade gjort.
Jo men någonstans måste man ändå vara öppen för att människor måste ju vara lyckliga, och de måste göra det som är rätt.
Jag tror att det är lika många anställda som har lämnat oss och som ångrat sig eller som kanske inte ens fick vara kvar hos oss.
Någonstans är det såhär, man måste just...
Vem på bolaget är den onda?
Om du nu är den goda här som tänker såhär, ni måste ju ha en ond person som funkar med som mig, som bara ringer upp de gamla...
Anders är ju kanske definitivt mer cynisk än vad jag är.
Men jag tror inte att man behöver vara god eller ond i det här.
Jag tror att det är mer att...
Man mår ju bättre av det själv också någonstans.
Jag tror ändå att man blir väldigt mycket lyckligare om man ser saker och ting positivt och också ändå är ärlig med hur saker och ting fungerar.
Man kan titta på en egen värld.
Om jag hade velat att alla skulle ha samma incitament som mig då skulle de ha samma ägande som mig, de skulle ha samma beslutsrätt, etc.
Och så är det ju inte.
Utan jag har ju valt att vara vd för juni, jag har valt att vara med och grunda juni.
Men det kommer väldigt mycket ansvar, men det kommer också väldigt mycket positivt.
Och det är någonting som är unikt för den här rollen.
Kanske möjligtvis Anders känner liknande.
Men det är ju någonting som jag måste också förstå och det kan man inte överföra till någon annan.
Och på samma sätt så...
Jag vet inte, jag tycker att det är...
Jag tror det viktiga är ju att man är tydlig och kommunikativ med varandra.
Om det är någon gång jag blir hård eller arg eller ledsen, då är det ju när det känns som att man har misslyckats, antingen att jag har misslyckats med att sätta rätt förväntningar och rätt kommunikation och rätt relation.
Men det kan även gå andra sidan, att man blir frågad sig vad den här personens intentioner är med olika saker och ting.
Jag får känslan att det funkar ungefär som jag där.
Man har förtroende för människor och sen när de har väl förbrukat det, då är man relativt iskall efter det.
Det finns inte.
Jag är inte iskall, jag ger ofta flera chanser, hoppas jag.
Oj okej, ja.
Jag, vad är, under den här resan som har varit nu, vad är du mest stolt över?
Ja men jag är ju extremt stolt över, egentligen två saker.
Ett, över de människorna vi lyckas få ihop.
Jag tycker att vi har ett extremt starkt team av, ja men, alltså starka individer, hög kompetens, erfarenheter som är väldigt svåra att få tillskänza sig.
Och att få ihop den här gruppen och bygga en kultur där människor kämpar väldigt hårt för att nå ett viss mål.
Det är en väldigt svår sak tror jag bara generellt sett.
Och det kräver att du lägger väldigt mycket både tid på det, men också underhåller det väldigt mycket.
Det som gör dig ännu mer stolt, kommit tillbaks till vårt förämne, är att jag känner det väldigt starkt även kring de människorna som inte är kvar hos oss.
Att vi har ändå, trots att människor kommer att gå och lyckas hålla den formen av högre kvalitet.
Det andra, och det kommer ju tillbaks där med hur svårt det är att bygga en bank, är att jag är väldigt stolt över att vi har lyckats bygga de här byggstenarna.
Oavsett hur mycket som finns kvar att göra, oavsett om det är perfekt eller inte, så har det varit en enorm utmaning att ens komma hit på egentligen tre och ett halvt år.
Bygga det vi har gjort på tre och ett halvt år, det tror jag är extremt få inom vår värld som förstår hur vi gjorde det.
Det kommer ju tillbaka till kanske då, vad det allting syftar till.
Det nöd inte vara jag mest stolt över, men vad det syftar till och det är att, jag är som alla andra människor, jag älskar också, bekräfte sig och känner mig behövd.
Det finns ju ingenting bättre än när de två bitarna, vår team och vår produkt genererar kunder som vill använda oss och som är nöjda och glada.
Och det är ju en enorm lycka.
Jag är väldigt stolt över att vi har de kunder vi har, och förhoppningsvis då att de kunderna i den absoluta majoriteten känner att vi bidrar och ger dem mer värde.
Ja, jag tänker, jag känner bara att jag måste fråga som slutfråga här lite att du har ju också investerat i några andra bolag vid sidan av Juni.
Jag vet inte hur många och sådär, men jag har bara sett ditt namn dyka upp här och där.
Ja, men det är tio, femton bolag.
Vad är det, eftersom du har gjort resan själv eller är fortfarande mitt i den och du har tagit in pengar, du har ju sett lite båda sidorna på ett intressant sätt.
Vad är det du letar efter hos dem du investerar i?
Nu ska jag säga att jag letar väldigt sällan.
Okej, vad är det du har godkänt som investeringsmöjligheter hos dem du har investerat i?
Ofta har det ju att göra med det som vi jobbar med, för jag gillar ju att lära mig mer om en bolagsbyggande och e-handel framförallt.
Så jag har ju investerat en stor del av, 15 har jag handlat om, framförallt att det är bolag inom antingen den svären, antingen de ekosystemet eller faktiska brands eller marketplaces.
Det jag letar efter mest är ju att man gör rätt.
Det här kan ju låta både enkelt och lite banalt, men det finns ändå ett antal steg, tror man, som entreprenörer kan göra, som underlättar väldigt mycket för att faktiskt nå framgång.
Hur man tänker kring feedback loop med kunder, hur man tänker kring TAM, alltså marknadsstorlek, hur man tänker kring go to market, hur man tänker kring sina finansiella planering, etc.
Det kommer egentligen tillbaks till en väldigt viktig sak, och det är ju så här, är du rätt person att bygga en lösning för det här problemet, och har du rätt team med dig.
Om man har gjort rätt i de här delarna väldigt tidigt, så är ju sannolikheten att man kommer att bygga någonting bra väldigt stor, eller väldigt mycket större ska jag säga.
Så det är det jag ofta ska kolla på, och det kommer ju ofta tillbaks till lite svårgreppbara, och kanske mycket gut feeling som handlar om att det här är en person du tror på.
Sen är det ju så här att i alla mina investeringar, så är jag helt övertygad om att alla kommer att gå till noll, jag räknar inte med att jag kommer att få ut någonting.
Vilken härlig bekräftelse för alla som lyssnar på detta som du har investerat i.
Nej men jag hoppas faktiskt att de känner så att jag inte räknar med någonting, för jag vill inte att de ska tro att det finns en förväntan att de här pengarna ska stiga någonting.
Jag är väldigt glad om de gör det, och såklart att jag har gjort en bedömning att de kan göra det, och om de lyckas så kanske jag har fått tillbaka 100x.
Men min utgångsläge är att rent statistiskt så måste du nog investera i ganska många fler bolag man har gjort för att hitta den formen av framgångssaga.
Och du måste vara mycket mer disciplinerad.
I det här avseendet så är jag...
Jag är ju som en person som har provat fyra restauranger, inte hundra, så att fråga mig om är det här den bästa restaurangen, det kommer ju baseras på det urvalet jag har.
Jag har ju ett informationsundertag som är ju enormt, men det är inte heller därför jag investerar så att säga.
Varför investerar du då?
Jag investerar för att lära mig mer och för att kunna ge tillbaka.
Och fem av femton investeringar har varit i människor som jag tror väldigt mycket på och som jag vill stötta.
Och det tycker jag är viktigt.
Menar du människorna eller företaget?
Människorna.
Jag tror att jag...
Jag menar, du har ju också sett det.
Det finns ju någon sån grundläggande indé inom startupvärlden att om man har möjlighet så ska man ge tillbaka.
Och det tycker jag är väldigt viktigt.
Och jag försöker ändå stötta personer som jag då tror på i olika sätt.
Sen är det ju alltid en problematik med tid.
Jag har ju väl lite tid att faktiskt vara med.
Och andra sidan ska jag säga att det gäller oftast de här entreprenörerna då.
Det finns ju ingenting som folk är lika dåliga på som att ge uppdateringar.
Det är extremt sällan jag får månadsrapporter som ängel i några av de här bolagen.
Vilket är ändå ganska fascinerande med tanke på hur jag själv upplever hur enkelt det borde vara att kunna säga så här går det, det här behöver jag hjälp med, etc.
Ja, jag köper det.
De är alla inkopplade i juni.
Ja, det hoppas jag verkligen.
Jag har tagit bort hälften av alla frågor jag hade tänkt ta här.
Jag hade kunnat sitta här i två timmar till.
Så du kör en sån, yo Rogan, tre timmars.
Ja, jag hade nog kunnat köra det faktiskt, men frågan när jag lyssnade hade jag orkat och plöda haft tid.
Jag är jättetacksam för att vi fick ta den här tiden och bara sitta och mata frågor.
Ja men tack så mycket, det var jättehärligt.
Vi får ta en fortsättning så här, vi kan ha en julavsnitt.
Exakt, exakt.
Nu är jag sämst på bolaget.
Nej, jag är inte bäst på någonting längre.